since Keanu Reaves first hit Hollywood
like a cool breeze in the 80s he saved
humanity from robot slavery kept a
doomed bus from exploding and even made
out with Paula Abdul but even though
Reid's is a pretty prolific actor he
remains far more enigmatic than many
other celebrities until now here are
some things you may not know about Keanu
Reeves Bart brain thanks to his roles as
dumb guy Ted in villain Ted's Excellent
Adventure and dumb guy Todd in
Parenthood Reeves was in danger of being
typecast in the early 90s now that's why
it was something of a surprise when
Kenneth Branagh cast Reeves as Don John
in his 1993 screen adaptation of William
Shakespeare's much ado about nothing but
Reeves had actually been performing
Shakespeare for years dating back to a
1985 production of Romeo and Juliet at a
Toronto theatre school and my own
Private Idaho was based on Shakespeare's
works how much does he love Shakespeare
he turned down a 12 million dollar offer
to star in speed too so that he could
play Hamlet in a stage production in
Manitoba Canada now that's love I had
rather be a canker in a hedge that arose
in His grace haunted by a jacket while
living in the New York area
young Reeves encountered what can only
be described as a ghost ghost jacket
anyway there's really no explanation so
let's just have Keano tell to tell
himself there's a doorway all of a
sudden we're looking over there and this
like jacket comes waving through the
doorway like just an empty there's no
head there's no body there's no legs
it's just there and then it disappears
and I was a little kid and I thought
okay well that's interesting and then I
looked over at the nanny and she's like
this
Wow he can't quit smoking while smoking
is often a youthful indiscretion Reeves
was willing to adulthood before he
picked up the habit he says he started
doing it on the set of the 1996 comedy
fooling Minnesota because his character
was a smoker and then he just got hooked
he's caught smoking a prison that he'd
love to quit foot can't personal
tragedies Reeves endured multiple
heartbreaking tragedies in rapid
succession he met actress and production
assistant Jennifer sim in 1998 and a
tooth fell in love in 1999
sim and Reeves were expecting a child
together but when sin was almost
full-term doctors discovered the baby
had passed away the stress of the loss
of the child contributed to the demise
of their relationship less than two
years later while driving home from a
party at Marilyn Manson's house in Los
Angeles sim was killed in a single car
accident she was only 28 years old
charity work
Reeves is very close with his sister Kim
Reeves who was diagnosed with leukemia
in the 90s filming on the Matrix
Reloaded and the Matrix Revolutions was
reportedly delayed so Keanu could spend
more time with his sister and help nurse
her back to health in Kim's honor
Keanu has donated huge amounts of his
time and money to cancer charities
hospitals and research facilities and a
foundation that does some you know it's
mostly directed towards you know
healthcare and he also works with
organizations like The Sick Kids
Foundation and stand up to cancer
film crew favorite while negotiating his
contract for the two Matrix sequels
Greaves scored a bunch of back-end
points meaning he'd make a portion of
the movies box-office tape in addition
to a salary instead of taking all the
cash for himself
Reeves diverted the money to The Matrix
trilogies costume and special effects
teams essentially donating millions so
the movies could be completed after the
production nearly ran out of cash he
also for each of the true G's twelve
stuntmen are Harley Davidson his way of
saying thanks pay cuts
if Reeves really wants to work with an
actor he admires he isn't a buff for
going a portion of his usual salary to
help make it happen he reportedly did
exactly that so that he could star in
the devil's advocate with Al Pacino and
in The Replacements with Gene Hackman
what's gonna be Shane I want the bar
winners always do motorcycle man Reeves
loves motorcycles so much that he
started his own business the arch
motorcycle company whose signature
product is the arch motorcycle kr gt1
designed and built with his friend and
arch co-founder bike architect Zaha
Linga the custom-built super bikes have
two v-twin engines and cost seventy
eight thousand dollars each rad Keanu
Reeves has often been an inspiration the
means viral pictures and the over
delight at the Internet among the most
famous a viral video of Keano giving up
his subway seat to someone who needed it
more then there's this uncanny 16th
century painting from the Uffizi gallery
in Florence Italy which seems to suggest
that Keano
is actually a time traveler himself and
of course there's the infamous sad Keanu
meme which actually made Keanu kind of
sad good not that sad I mean do I wish
that I didn't get my picture taken and
while I was eating a sandwich on the
streets of New York yeah not quite the
world Stallions shortly after the
release of the
Ted movies Reeves filmed a garage band
who dug stir in his actual garage I
played in a band called dog star and we
made a couple of albums
I played electric bass at their first
gig an up-and-coming band coryza was
their opening act and dog star even
played The Tonight Show
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment and let us know
which fact about Keanu Reaves
surprised you the most